resistance which we call strong
approximation resistance and I'll Define
the terms as we go along okay so first
well the basic things we'll talking
about kcps uh you have n Boolean
variables M constraints and they look
like this right so you can have sat
constraints or cut constraints on a
graph where you're just saying that the
vertices do not get the same label if
they share an edge between them and so
on and so forth and this is one of the
most fundamental classes of problems y y
y and so on so I mean that's sort of
things I guess has been said quite a few
times by
now uh so let me just set up some
notation and let me Define uh 3xr in in
plus minus one variabl so you have three
you have variables which are supposed to
be plus or minus one and you have some
constraints on their products of some
three doues
okay and you can write it in a way that
the right hand side is is the same for
all of them and some variables have been
multiplied by a negative sign okay and
in general if you are given some
predicate uh which takes K plus or minus
one variables output Z or one you can
think of each constraint as as this
predicate F applied to a kle of
variables some of them possibly negated
right so just let's denote whether the
variable is negated or Not by ass sign b
u sub one I for the ath constraint and
the first variable in the ath constraint
and so on okay so it's the notation okay
just I guess it's fairly standard so so
again we'll be studying the question of
finding the maximum fraction of
satisfiable constraints and the notion
of approximating them so you approximate
within a factor gamma if you want if you
can decide whether the fraction of
satisfiable constraints by an assignment
is more than gamma * Theta or less than
Theta if you can solve this problem for
all Theta then you have a gamma
approximation algorithm and if there's
some Theta for which you cannot solve it
then that's a gamma in approximability
result okay uh and approximation
resistance kind of comes from the
maximum possible Gap you can have
between the red and the green regions
here so let's Define row of f which is a
parameter which measures if you if you
plug in a random assignment what's the
probability that a constraint will be
satisfied constraint according to F
uh uh right so for 3 sat it's 78 for XR
it's half and so on and we call function
f approximation resistant if we have
this kind of an inapproximability result
which is it's hard to distinguish
between when you can satisfy almost all
constraints or no more than row of F and
again the way row of f is defined U it's
trivial to satisfy row of a fraction of
constraints just by using a random
assignment and to be more correct f is
approximation resistant if for every
Epsilon greater than zero we have an
approximability result of this form
okay and as I said it captures the
notion of it hard to do better than a
random
assignment
okay right
so we'll be talking of characterizations
but before that let me just sort of say
some of the sufficient conditions or
some that have been known to imply
approximation resistance and this is the
first classic result which is I guess
from 97 in the journal version from 2001
all when I was in high school uh is that
sat and XR are approximation resistant
on NK variables for K greater than equal
to
three and uh H took it quite a bit
further on studying predicates on four
variables and and out of 400 of
non-trivial nonisomorphic and predicates
which are not isomorphic to each other
he classified 79 of them to be
approximation resistant 275 to be not so
and the remaining 46 are open as far as
I know okay so what I mean was quite an
extensive bit of
work and some classes of predicates
which have been shown to be
approximation resistant uh so I'll use a
star for results which are about unique
games hardness or which assume unique
games conjecture so so the result of
suin trisan from 2006 which was
converted into NP hardness by Chan which
I guess you heard it talk about in the
morning is that certain classes of
predicates instead of exor if you think
of an and of exor which can be thought
of as a Subspace of F2 to the K and if
these subspaces have some nice
properties then uh f f is approximation
resistant okay and the nice property is
that well given that it is a Subspace
when I look at the uniform distribution
of f inverse one or on the satisfying
assignment that's a pairwise independent
distribution and it's balanced so every
bit is one or minus one with equal
probability and every pair has all four
configurations with probability 1/4
okay if you want only unique games
hardness there's an beautiful
generalization of this result which is
uh you don't need this Subspace property
but as long as there exists any balanced
and pairwise independent distribution
which is supported on the satisfying
assignments the the predicate is
approximation resistance and this is the
rest result of a from
2009 so these are all sufficient
conditions which show a fairly large
class of predicates to be approximation
resistant and I must say if you look at
random predicates almost all predicates
have these kind of properties so it's
it's a fairly large
class the characterization so the
previous to this work was by atin and
cot which is in some special cases where
f is even which means if you flip all
the variables the value of the predicate
does not change and the instance is
required to be karti so that's sort of a
restriction not just on the predicate
but on what kind of problem instance you
are given so each constraint so you can
think of your variables being arranged
as in in K layers and each constraint
picks its first variable from the first
layer second from the second layer and
so on and so forth okay and you talk of
U sort of so it it is conceivable that
if you have this Arrangement the problem
will become easier or some instance will
become easier to solve without then
without this uh uh without this
condition on the instance and so this
characterization is not necessarily the
same as a characterization of General
instances and we believe it's somewhat
restrictive okay so let me change the
question a little bit and instead of
approximation resistant if resistance if
you look at what we call strong
approximation
resistance the problem
becomes somewhat easier to understand
and the sort of nice characterizations
that follow so let me at least Define
what that notion is before we talk about
it so just to recall if is approximation
resistant if it's well we have some kind
of hardness NP hardness or unique games
hardness about distinguishing these two
cases in in strong approximation
resistance the two cases are either more
most of the constraints are satisfiable
or the fraction of constraints
satisfiable by any assignment is
essentially around what a random
assignment would do okay you cannot even
satisfy much less than a random
assignment okay or it's hard to
distinguish between those two cases so
it's sort of a promised problem but with
a stronger
promise so in one case you have this in
the other case you have a promise of
this kind and you still want to
distinguish between them okay in terms
of an algorithm you want to think of an
algorithm uh given an instance which is
1 minus Epsilon satisfiable the
algorithm wants to do anything different
from a random assignment either it wants
to satisfy more than row of f plus
Epsilon or less than row of f minus
Epsilon but not within this interval and
find something different okay
so I said so this categorize when is it
possible or not possible to do anything
at all which is different from a random
assignment I mean depending on how you
believe this could also be a fairly
natural notion to study at least as far
as we are comparing ourselves with
random assignment or trivial algorithms
okay is is a notion of strong
approximation resistance okay okay and
sort of a simple observation that for
odd predicates where if you flip the
sign of all the variables the value of
the predicate changes this is equivalent
to approximation resistant because if
you have an assignment which does row of
f plus Epsilon if you flip every bit
it'll have row of f it'll satisfy row of
f minus Epsilon fraction of constraints
okay so just if if you can do row f plus
Epsilon you can do row F minus Epsilon
and vice verse actually which is an
important part and also I should say
that previously all known results in the
PCP literature except for one that I
know by hust uh actually pro strong
approximation resistant because the way
you prove such a result is by applying
some kind of invariance principle which
bounds the absolute value of the term
you get when you analyze the PCP which
is absolute value of everything other
than row of f right and once you get a
bound on the absolute value you are
actually proving strong approximation
resistance so almost any result which
uses invariance principle ends up
proving strong approximation so it's
it's not a completely bizar notion it's
been studied at least implicitly in all
all the hardness results now
okay all right so before I go to a
characterization that we will give
there's also already sort of a
characterization which follows from The
Works of rag the RTO okay so it's a
characterization in the following sense
so prasad's result very beautiful result
from 2008 which shows that if you have
an integrality gap for some kind of
natural sdp relaxation which is some
kind of a hard instance then you have a
a hardness of approximation result again
assuming you games conjecture and hence
the star okay an integrality Gap is just
sort of a concrete instance where some
basic sdp relaxation U has which is an
sort of
some kind of optimization program has
value which is supposed to be the
fraction of constraint satisfiable and
the value of the sdp is close to one
whereas actually on that instance you
cannot satisfy more than row of f plus
Epsilon fraction of constraints and if
such an instance exists then the f is
approximation resistant and vice versa
because the Prasad showed the
equivalence between these two
Nations uh and what the work
ofad and David ster from 2009 shows is
that if you're looking for such an
instance you don't have to go too far uh
such an instance will only always you
can always find such an instance with
size at most W exponential in epsilon
okay so this is uh sort of a recursively
a numerable characterization right I
mean you want to check if for every
Epsilon uh there exists an integrality
Gap instance which is 1us Epsilon versus
row of f plus Epsilon so just do a Brute
Force search on all instances of this
size and keep going for smaller and
smaller Epsilon and I mean if for some
Epsilon you cannot find such an instance
then you can say that this is not
approximation resistant and otherwise
you just keep going
okay so that's in that sense it's a
recurs it's a characterization but I
call it a partial characterization
because it sort of doesn't explain what
properties of f actually give us the
yeah
sorry oh is it um perhaps I was mistaken
can tell us if the size is a Sly or dou
exponential
but there was some sort of log in the
correction procedure of well at most EXP
fos exponential is definitely correct
but okay
so that's true okay still a true
statement fortunately um hopefully so in
terms of characterization I'm looking
for what properties of f give right to
such hard instances I mean so far what
we have said is f is hard if there
exists a hard instance witnessing it but
that's doesn't feel sort of a proper
characterization in particular I'm
looking for something on the lines of a
most result which says well if such a
nice pair wise independent distribution
exists then f is approximation resistant
or something on those
lines okay and also the second question
I can ask which um uh is that whether
it's just the property of F that um
makes the instance hard or or is it
something about how you choose the
different constraints which fit together
in an integrality Gap instance and
integrality GAP has and sort of whether
the first variable should be shared
between the first constraint and the
10th constraint and so on and so forth
so is it the topology of the instance
that is important or is just properties
of f okay and well you can kind of get a
hint from what we're talking about okay
so so this is the kind of
characterization I'm looking for and
I'll give you one for strong strong
approximation resistance in this talk
okay so before we go there let me set up
some notation and and okay just to
mention I said this argument about 1
minus Epsilon versus row f plus Epsilon
but the whole thing also works for
strong approximation resistant so it
gives a characterization in this form of
strong approximation resistance also the
results of plus than D okay so let me
State theal condition in different
language and sort of also set up some
notation okay so let's consider any
Distribution
on uh plus minus one to the K and let's
consider
the single and first and second moments
of that distribution okay so you sample
in X from that distribution look at the
I bit of X and look at its bias or the
correlation between I and J bit okay and
just look at this collection this Vector
of all the moments which has K plus K2
coordinates and let's just call it Zeta
of mu
okay and let's define this polytope
which is a convex polytope where you
collect all such moment vectors for any
distribution which is supported on
satisfying assignments
okay um and our characterization will be
in terms of this polytop but before that
the osal condition is saying that zero
is in this polop right you have Vector
which is B
implies z i are zero and pairwise
Independence means Z is zero for every I
not equal okay so this is a sufficient
condition of a musel and our condition
will be in some kind of will be in terms
of so this condition is in terms of
existence of a certain point inside this
polytope and if you look at some other
results by U Hast there're also about
existence of certain other points in
this polytop with where you don't have
all coordinates to be zero but but sort
of some of them can be negative or
positive in some especially chosen way
okay uh our condition will be in terms
of existence of some measure on this
polytope and if a measure satisfying
certain kind of symmetry properties
exists then f is approximation resistant
and more importantly if it does not
exist then f is not approximation
resistant so it's a necessary and like
sufficient and necessary condition okay
any questions at this point or about
this
notation
yes exactly so a point in this polytop
is of the form Z mu right so zero is in
this polytope means there exists a mu or
there exists a point in this poo which
is of this form which is equal to zero
so Z of mu is equal to Z for some mu
right a point in this poop exactly
corresponds to Zeta of mu for some mu
right I mean a convex combinations of
distributions also are distribution so
any point in this poop is conx yeah
sorry yeah it's con con that's con yeah
yeah it's convex yeah I'm not taking a
convex
okay right
so so before I go to those symmetry
conditions let me tell you some ways of
transforming a measure Lambda on this
basically I'll tell you some way of
transforming every point in this polytop
and a transformation of of a measure
will be defined with respect to some
natural Transformations on the points
and then the Symmetry conditions I can
State more conveniently in terms of
those so let me so these are some
natural operations that come up you sort
of
see why they come up is sort of in the
proof but it's easy to see the
conditions as such okay so suppose we
have uh Zeta which is I should remind
you is a is a vector of first and second
moments okay and of some K some
distribution corresponding to Plus on
plusus one to the K okay so maybe I can
permute the underlying K variables and
that will sort of permute the
coordinates of Zeta in some natural way
right the I coordinate will go to the pi
coordinate and I coordinate will go to
Pi I Pi J for the second correlation
right so this is a fairly natural
transformation of a
point I can multiply a variable by a
sign and I variable by sign bi so the
moment corresponding to I will be
multiplied by bi and the moment
corresponding to i j will be multiplied
by B * BJ this is again a fairly natural
transformation of a point or which
corresponds to like well every point in
the support of some distribution I just
multiply by like the coordinate bybi
okay and maybe I can choose to sort of
restrict myself to some subset of
variables some subset s of the K
variables instead of all of them so if
the subset has says uh T then I will get
a vector of size t plus T ch2 instead of
K plus K CH 2 Okay so this will be some
kind of projection of a point Zeta and
then if I apply all three of them to
each point in the support of some
measure I get some sort of natural
transformation of that measure okay so
this is so when I say Lambda s pi b this
is what I'll mean I have some set s
which is a subset of the K variables uh
some permutation on the set and some
sort of signing of the set and I apply
the
transformation these transformation to
every point in the support of Lambda and
I get a natural measure s pi b
okay and just to get some practice so if
Lambda is supported only on the point
zero no matter what transformation I
apply I still get the point zero but for
example if Lambda was supported only on
the point all once then if I apply
identity permutation if I keep all K
points and I apply multiply by this B I
will get this point which is a
completely different point so it's a
it's a measure which is supported on a
completely disjoint support okay these
two okay so just to make sure uh that
doing this transformation can completely
shift Lambda to a different
support is is the definition of the
measure and the transformation
okay all right so once we have these
symmetries it's U kind of easy to State
our
characterization
and okay so recall I mean a workshop in
for analysis I guess this is fairly easy
I can write f in it for basis and the
characterization is that it's strongly
approximation resistant if and only if
there exists some measure
Lambda
uh such that a condition holds for all t
or all fora levels and at each fora
level I want sort of some signed
combination of of these measure of this
transformations of my original measure
to vanish and by vanish I mean these are
identically zero functions okay this
this is a function
on t plus T choose two coordinates and
it's identically zero so for example if
Lambda was supported on some point and
this transformation was supported on
some completely different points they
will not cancel so you have to be like
you have to say when it's a zero
function but okay so it's some condition
and we'll see a little bit more about
that but before that let me give you
some sort of idea of how this comes
about or what the proof looks like okay
so we want to study these two cases the
this sort of obvious that either a
Lambda satisfying those conditions exist
or it does not when it exists proving at
least unique games hardness is uses
relatively standard ideas in particular
ideas of like prad's reduction which of
which basically samples some kind of U
muse from this Lambda and then construct
a dictatorship test according to that mu
in some sort of standard way and this is
not I mean pretty much all sufficient
condition like sufficient conditions for
approximation resistant are prooved this
way and there's not much new
here uh it's sort of the other thing
which is if no such Lambda exists then
we want show that it's not approximation
resistant or it's not strongly
approximation resistant and to do this
we actually set up another dichotomy
which is between which is kind of a Zer
some game between an algorithm and
hardness player okay and somehow their
value is supposed to capture how
different different from a random
assignment you are and I'll describe
this game a little more in the next
slide but
uh if you have this Zero Sum game and
the value is defined appropriately the
other direction becomes easy easier from
this dichotomy sort of the value is
defined precisely in a way that when
value is greater than zero you get an
algorithm which shows that it's not
strongly approximation
resistant and most of the work is
actually relating these two dichotomies
or sort of showing that when uh the
value is equal to zero a good Lambda
exists or of well and it has the
necessary symmetry properties and so on
and so forth and by contrapositive it
sort of also shows the other so that so
yeah the bulk of the paper is just
relating these two Notions so let me say
something more about this Zero Sum game
and at least tell you how to define the
value okay and let me say this sort of a
game which between two like players
algorithm and hardness was also used by
Odon and Wu for Max cut and then they
wanted to characterize what's the right
hardness Threshold at certain points and
so on okay so we have two players the
algorithm and hardness the hardness
player tries to design an integrality
Gap instance integrality Gap instance
corresponds to a bunch of constraints
and in these sdps each constraints has
has K variables and there are vectors
corresponding to each of the variables
which have pair wise in our products
which gives you pair wise correlations U
and so on so if you look at a particular
constraint it gives you some Zeta and if
you look at the distribution over all
constraints it gives you a Lambda so
over all constraints in a single
instance so intuitively a hardness
player tries to design a hard instance
and his strategies are just lambdas and
I'm saying the way I'm defining the game
it's infinite in fact the set of
strategies uncountably infinite but
there are ways to handle
that the algorithm player tries to come
up with a rounding strategy so given an
instance the rounding strategy is sort
of the most natural thing to do you
project uh some vectors that you are
given to some D dimensional gaussian
space and then for each point in that
space you decide whether when the
projection lands there you'll label it
plus or minus one the variable okay so a
strategy for the algorithm player is
this one and I sort of show how the
value of the game is decided by this
okay but these are the two set of
strategies and the value is supposed to
be uh the ABS like the deviation from
random the expected fraction of satis
constraint Satisfied by this uh rounding
strategy s when when the instance is
captured by Lambda and obviously when
the value is greater than zero it means
that there exists around strategy or
maybe a distribution of rounding
strategies which which Witnesses the
fact that for every Lambda you can have
a positive deviation uh from zero right
and for every Lambda because of this
correspondence sort of corresponds in a
natural way to for every given instance
so U the way the value is defined this
part fairly easily gives an algorithm in
terms of rounding or once you have the
value greater than
zero and so let me just Define the value
of the game and well say two words about
it
so so as I said um you can think of a
hard instance as being captured by this
Lambda so each constraint is given by
some Zeta where you think of K variables
in that constraint and all pair wise
correlations are given by the vectors
corresponding to uh those K
variables okay and usually there are
local distributions over every kle in
all these sdps so these are all valid
points in the
polto and
so the algorithm player is given these
vectors whose inner products correspond
to this entries of Zeta and he tries to
round it uh and by rounding I mean of IT
projects them to some sort of gussian
space to gaussian y1 to YK and these
will just have a correlation Matrix
which corresponds to Zeta where pairwise
correlations will be according to the
entries of Zeta okay so you'll just get
Kian with this distribution and so the
expected fraction of con straint
satisfied is uh on the probability of
picking a random constraint uh with a
random projection to the gaussians of
the corresponding variables when you
apply the rounding strategy is f
satisfied or not right and you can
expand it in the fora basis and so on
and so forth so this term comes out and
what remains is what is defined as the
value of the game okay pretty
much and and then the rest of the whole
deal is to analyze this expression and
understand it a little
better and just my last slide on talk um
so this is a value and the value being
zero means that there exists a Lambda or
actually a distribution over lambdas
which gives a value zero for Al right
that's what the value being zero in a
min max game means or zero s game
means and if you think of this value you
can view it as a polinomial in again the
infinitely many
variables corresponding to values of
this function s at all points in R to
the D okay and what I'm saying is this
polinomial is zero for all assignments
to this variable C of Y for every Y and
this you can use to conclude that all
coefficients are zero and if you think
of the coefficients they come out to be
some kind of linear combinations of
integrals of these measures and so on
and with some analysis You can conclude
that uh if the integrals are zero with
sort of all the rest right densities
then the measure linear combinations of
measures themselves are zero and so on
and this last line takes about 30 pages
to write down but beyond that sort of
that's the of okay so that's sort of the
idea in in a sort of cartoon
way and say that um we also characterize
approximation res because the notion is
equivalent to approximation resistance
for odd predicates we characterize
approximation resistance including
threshold predicates which pass through
the origin because they're odd also we
get a characterization of for K parte
instances uh for odd or even predicates
and we get characterizations of shali
Adams LP gaps or sort of when do gaps
exist and so on and so forth and of
course the open problems are first is
the the condition this one is also
recursively enumerable like Prasad and
David's condition but is it decidable
and we don't know and can you say that
this Lambda is always finitely supported
so far the results have one point but we
need a measure and we don't know a bound
on the support size okay and of course s
of strong approximation resistance
versus approximation resistance can you
find predicates which are one but not
the other so and so on and yeah I stop
here
questions yes so are you able to use the
characterization to classify new
predicates or uh well so far we haven't
in principle we can run a computer
search and in particular on threshold
predicates and so on where the question
is interesting but so far we haven't
done it I
mean is there anything surprising that
comes out sorry well
characterization as a result in terms of
what can we characterize as I said we
haven't done aarch on it it was well at
least slightly surprising to me that
there was a characterization but uh uh
in terms of particular predicate we
don't know yet
yeah nice example case where the measure
is not just an atom at zero or it's
apprx no all results are just have an
atom well not zero but some nonzero
point but they are all an
atom I think uh if one is brave enough
to actually
uh write programs and do computer
searches I think many many surprising
things will turn up start we are
basically I guess sort of there is sort
of a trivial example where it's not an
atom in some in the sense that uh in if
I understand correctly in papers of
Johan and per you need some certain
coordinates to be zero and the others
are just required to be either positive
or negative in some sort of specific
condition some moments are only just
positive or just negative yeah but you
just need one measure well yeah so if
you exhibit a point it is true but you
can take a collection of points without
properties and it'll still be true
that's just in a trivial sense that it's
a nonconcentrated measure but it's still
not clear if you need them I mean you
don't need it yeah yeah you don't need
it but
uh so it's a very trivial example that's
yeah so I mean is the ALR also known to
be T I mean it possible it's also
necessary so in particular the example
of in paper of and Yan that I was
mentioning it is a predicate which does
not satisfy like does not exist any
pairwise independent Distribution on its
support but it's still approximation
resistant okay so it's a yeah it shows
that it's not
tight any other questions so you don't
have a suggestion for what is a real uh
no for character characterization for
approximating for for
assistant
um the example in in the paper of your
is is that also strong approximation or
is it just it's not known well um s i I
think it's not known to be strongly
approximation
um actually there are a bunch of
examples but at least the one that is a
modification of H example sign of the
quadratic or yeah JJ
predicate so because there because of
the positivity conditions you don't
analyze the absolute value
so so do you know a difference between
strong approximation resist like no so
that was one of my problems we don't
know an exact I mean that example might
actually be one which is approximation
resistant but not strongly approximation
resistant but I don't know if an
explicit
example
yeah so there is just one predicate in
the paper
ofan which is if you are brave enough I
think you should one should be able to
just search it and prove that it is uh
my gu is that it probably will not be
strongly resistant and that will be an
example which is resistant but not
strongly
resistant but we don't
know yeah isn't this more complicated
then the some water
resistance well I'm kind of familiar
with both results I'm sort of a bad
judge so my favorite notion that you
didn't notice mention because I
introduced myself is
uselessness Right a different notion but
which is an even stronger notion I guess
from strong I think but it should really
be called super strong resistance but
you have a different perspective and you
call it useless yeah I mean it's
stronger than strong resistance I guess
because strong resistance just
corresponds to uselessness with k equals
p and 1 minus P yes yes and then you
have an or q and you have an arbitrary Q
in your
notion for Q do you get
anything um yeah I think the whole
thing also works for Q but uh I don't
think we wrote it down I
mean
I mean I don't think there's a problem
with Q as far as I
know but could it be that this
characterizes approxim measure
assistance uh it could be I mean because
again there's no counter example to this
in terms of strong for approximation
resistance either we don't know that the
predicate in your paper is s of does not
satisfy this
characterization and again as subash
said we've been a bit cowardly in
computer searches that's sort of the
okay
other comments or
questions okay
thanks now we only have a short break of
s minutes
until uh